روسيا بدات حربا في اوكرانيا توقعتها
سريعه وانها سترضع حلف شمال الاطلسي
للابتعاد عن الحدود الروسيه وهذا لم يحدث
روسيا تتخذ موقفا حادا ضد توسع الناتو الى
الشرق وتعتبر انه سيزيد التوتر في اوروبا
لذلك قامت في ديسمبر الماضي بنشر مسوده
اتفاقيات بينها والولايات المتحده والنيت
بشان الضمانات الامنيه والتي تنص على
الالتزام بعدم توسع الناتو شرقا انطلقت
حرب اوكرانيا وبدات دول مجاوره لروسيا
مسيعيها للانضمام كي لا تقع في مازق مشابه
لاوكرانيا وفيما الماضي تقدمت السويد
وفنلندا دولتان المحايدتان اصلا بطلب
الرسمي للانضمام للحلف حينها اعتبر الرئيس
الروسي ان تحرك الدولهتين
الاسكندنافيه لا يهدد موسكو بشكل مباشر
لكنه شدد على ان يتوسع في البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه من شانه ان يؤدي الى ردد من
الكرم
توقع خبراء روسبال توقعوا انه من جمله
الاجراءات الممكنه ان تنشر روسيا مجموعه
دفاع صاروخي وجوي جديده في الشمال الغربي
وعسكرت منطقه كالينغراد وبيلاروسيا وتعزيز
اساطير البلطيق والشمال
[موسيقى]
فنلندا والسويد الى النيترو سيزيده مساحه
حدود الحلف مع روسيا
1300 كيلو متر تمثل طول الحدود بين
البلدين مصدر قلق فنلندا ياتي من التاريخ
القديم
في بلادهم وسط الصراع مع المانيا
للسلام في الثالث عشر من مارس من عام 1940
وفي ايامنا الحاليه تتخوف فنلندا كذلك
تتخوف من ان يعيد سيناريو حرب الشتاء نفسه
وتقدمت بطلب الانضمام للنيته الذي مازال
معلقه ايضا عرضت فنلندا على اوكرانيا
تدريب جنودها استعدادا لحرب الشتاء
المتوقعات قريبا
[موسيقى]
من العاصمه نيوزلانديه برزت تصريحات ادلت
بها رئيسه الوزراء الفلنديه سنه مارين
خلال مؤتمرها مع نظيرتها جسددا مارين طلبت
بتقديم المزيد من الاسلحه والدعم
لاوكرانيا لضمان انتصارها في حرب هذا
الدروسيا اضافت رئيسه الوزراء الفنديه ان
الدول بحاجه لاظهار القوه الصلبه عندما
يتعلق الامر باوكرانيا التي تحتاج بحسب
مرين للاسلحه والدعم المالي والانساني كما
طلبت مريم دول الغربيه بالتشديد العقوبات
على روسيا بسبب تاثير الحرب الذي يطال
الجميع كالمدانيين في اوكرانيا اضافه
لجميع الشعوب العالم جراء ارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه
[موسيقى]
الحرب في اوكرانيا تبدو ملموسه جدا من
وجهه نظر فنلندا لاننا نتقسم حدودا طويله
مع روسيا كنا سابقا في حاله حرب مع روسيا
لذا فالوضع ملموس جدا للشعب الفنلندي
اوكرانيا بحاجه للدعم وعلينا التاكد من
انتصارهم في الحرب فهم بحاجه الى المزيد
من الاسلحه ارسلنا سابقا 10 دفعه من
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا ونحتاج ايضا للتاكد
من ان العقوبات اصعب واقصى ضد روسيا
قال وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شوشو ان
الدولتين احرزتا بعد التقدم في الاستجابه
لمخاوف انقر الامنيه بعد اجتماع مع نظيره
من فنلندا
ولم توافق تركيا
بتجاهل التهديدات التي تتعرض لها تركيا من
قبل المسلحين الاكراد والجماعه الاخرى
التي تعتبرها ارها حتى الان صادق الثمانيه
وعشرون دوله من دول الناتو 30 على طلبي
الانضمام بينما لم يصادق البرلمان التركي
كذلك نظره المجاري الهنجاري واوضح وزير
الخارجيه التركيه ان السويد وفنلندا بحاجه
لاقناع الشعب التركي والبرلمان التركي من
جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه السويدي ان
المحادثات مع تركيا احرزت بعض التقدم
باتجاه موافقه تركيا على انضمام السويد
وفنلندا
[موسيقى]
وتركيا وشعارت بعد الاجتماع بوجود تقدم في
هذا الاتجاه نحن نتحرك قدما في تنفيذ
مذكره ثلاثيه تم توقيعها في مدريد ويتم
القيام بذلك على عده مستويات واخطط قريبا
لرحله الى تركيا للقاء زميلي مولود شهود
اوغلو في انقره
مراسلنا في اسطنبول
يطلعون الان على الجانب من المطالب
التركيه وماذا تبقى من دوني تنفيذ
يتوجب على فنلندا والسويد تقديم المزيد
بانقره حتى تعطي ضوءا اخضر لدخولهم الناتو
هذا ما اكله وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود
شاويش اوغلو بعد لقاء مع وزراء خارجيه
البلدين في بخارست على هامش اجتماع لحلف
شمال الاطلسي الوزير التركي ذكر بالتحديد
تسليما فنلندا والسويد لمطلوبين للحكومه
التركيه مرحبا في الوقت ذاته بالتزام
الحكومتين بما قال انها الاليه الجديده
لمكافحه الارهاب اذا انقر ما زالت تريد
المزيد من هيلسنكي
الاتراك لا يريدون فقط تصنيف حزب العمال
الكردستاني كنظيم الارهابي في هاتين
الدولتين بل تسليما المطلوبين وتجميد اصول
بعد التنظيمات التي تصنفها انقر
بالارهابيه ايضا تسعى تركيا في مفاوضاتها
مع الدولتين ومع الغرب الى رفع حظر صادرات
السلاح عنها ايضا تسعى تركيا في مفاوضاتها
مع الدولتين الغرب الى رفع حظر صادرات
السلاح عنها ورغم ان معظم القضايا يمكن
حلها لكن القضيه العالقه الابرز ستبقى
تسليم المطلوبين